hello friends I'm Ilana and welcome to
my channel before you stop watching this
video I just wanted to let you guys know
mice allowed call good stuff
hello friends I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel before you start watching
this video I just wanted to let you know
that it is basically like a highlights
clip or an excerpt from a full episode
of my podcast red lips orange car which
as you can see on screen is all about
miss connections and relationship advice
and crazy weird funny stories that we
find on the internet so if you want to
listen to a full hour-long version of
this show you will be able to catch this
particular episode on May 15th but there
are already a bunch of episodes up there
pretty much timeless so go check it out
it's on all your podcast services enjoy
the show
thank you for watching ok this one is
called you are lactating and sold me
your milk many times 4w this is some
florida [ __ ] for sure yes
you know what's crazy email wait what
are you family and I'll endow up to
Ethan why I mean hopefully now selling
their breast milk but I mean Orlando
Florida is kind of like the rainforest
would this be legal selling someone your
breast milk I think no I think it's
illegal to sell someone bodily fluids
right is it I think it is maybe that's
on a state-by-state basis well it'll win
a game ago both what if I was going by I
think that people did try to argue that
that would technically be illegal in
some states because it could have like
human matta in it allowed to yeah I
think so I don't think you're allowed
anyway this one says legal really yep
and a lot of people actually donate or
sell their breast milk you know
apparently so a man for babies I bet it
oh that makes sense
mail it I bet you're not supposed to
mail mmm that because that makes a bio
husband exactly what I think might be
illegal okay he's fine yeah
completely fine it continues by saying
met in parking lot each time age age 50
new though they're all like stories
about those women who keep breastfeeding
their kids so they're like 15 and [ __ ]
that happens to mama way too early
oh man it's messed up okay you are
married and we're lactating about a year
and a half ago know who I married was
relevant that I met you several times
and bought your milk we had a bit of fun
but you seemed to want more it freaked
me out I really just wanted your breasts
and the fun that goes along with your
milk I didn't want sex now I miss you
and sure wish we could connect again as
you know I was quite generous with you
and would be again bring back things
this happened in Tampa we met at the
side of a store each time we were very
discreet but you seemed to want more
than I wanted to offer physically if
you're still open to things please
message me okay you know the reason I
really around the reason I really wanted
to pick this one is that I love that
this dude was like I was very freaked
out by you wanting sex I really just
wanted that milk in theory she probably
doesn't have the milk now and he's like
but I still want it anyway I just he
wanted this understand that we don't
lack take forever I know
start lactating that's it you just
forever lactate uh-huh so my guess is
you guys don't have to go to the grocery
store though right what like you could
just get milk anytime you want get out
of here Oh goddamn it no but uh yeah
it's so the reason I wanted to talk
about this one is the amount of change
that would happen in that time from from
what I'm reading they met up maybe he
sucked on a titty yep
seems that way it probably turned her on
or something and he was like whoa no I'm
not about that sex what about the Lord
or whatever because Florida is that a
religious state I don't know yeah okay
we'll take it um I love this romantic
comedy because I didn't want it he
wasn't into it now and then a year and a
half later he's like should have [ __ ]
a [ __ ]
that seems like what has happened here
which I found absolutely fascinating
because sometimes you can miss someone I
don't know that these people know each
other very well they met several times
behind a stole he sucked at it II she
would go on her way has child and
husband she wanted sex marital problems
maybe want having sex often often she
had a kid it happens I've read stuff
like that very complicated but now he
wants someone he's never even actually
had really they basic when you have a
weird sorry excuse me I don't want a
king shame because we all have weird
kinks but when you have a unique sort of
fetish and you meet somebody who has a
similar fetish and is willing to engage
in that fetish with you and then you
cannot find somebody else who's willing
to engage in that fetish you go [ __ ]
like let me let me call that girl up
again hmm but she could no longer
provide the fetish so in in your dream
of this rom-com are they now meeting up
I don't know she's a bit uptight I feel
like this needs to be like more free
loving kind of no kidding way more free
loving titty milk loving lady that's
Sandra Bullock like ela Fisher yeah I
like that I like that okay okay yeah
yeah she [ __ ] impress me okay yeah
we've decided it's Canada yeah no so I
Chloe your version of this rom-com means
that while she probably is no longer
lactating and Nola me can produce milk
they're gonna go off on like
breastfeeding adventures together
ideally because she's pulled it she's
lactating
permanently I really do I think this guy
doesn't understand I think like maybe he
thinks that she might either have
another baby or I think that it's just a
continuous stream for him in his mind do
you think if they went together and he
had the lactating fetish he would be one
of those dudes who was like keep
breastfeeding baby yeah and if she
stopped he'd be like no that's it when
you start bringing it
bring kids into it yeah yeah kids what
present while this woman was going and
doing this which is honestly fine like
as long as the kids still getting milk
which I imagined they were I think it
works that way you know you're do you
the combination of also she's married
and she's got kids and she's like
meeting a guy in a park it's not
cheating I'm just giving a girl milk no
I was gonna bring that up like is that I
don't know listen she tried to have sex
with him as far as I'm concerned I think
you can snip accont act cheating but if
you just like squirt it into the air and
then he catches it not cheating I think
I'm even of the impression that like to
get into like what cheating is I feel
like that's on a relationship by
relationship basis or whatever a person
by person but I even feel like like
intent like show and dramatic intent to
[ __ ] someone still counts as cheating
and she definitely wanted to just got
rejected
regarding kiddy milk is probably just
cheating I assume yeah yeah husband
might have been cool with it though who
knows he could have been completely fine
with it could have been like no it
doesn't say how they met but I imagine
they did weird like titty milk I mean
surely there is a forum for it I imagine
this is a prevalent kink i I remember I
think I was listening to a podcast I
can't remember which one and a guy tells
the story about how a stripper lactated
into his mouth and I think it might have
been Chris D'Elia he's telling a story
about one of his friends and yeah a
stripper lactated in his mouth and the
guy was super into it yeah but he didn't
expect it it was a surprise like a
surprise little titty squat in his mouth
but he didn't see coming but he was like
and you know it yeah I remember it
specifically because Chris D'Elia goes
and that was a thing that he said like
over over and over but yeah I don't know
I don't know how prevalent this is but I
imagine it's a prevalent thing because
you know humans exist and thus anything
about them can be sexualized and so
we'll so I imagine there's a big
off the people into titty milk so I
guess we've established yes cheating I
still want to want to divulge the
question as if they met up again and she
wasn't lactating do you think he'd just
be disappointed like he says I miss you
but do you bro
do you though no I think he just missed
that titty milk yeah they're a thing
where you can sort of pretend like I'm
sure there's some sort of like weird
contraption like the fact is even if you
you she's into it is what I'm saying
yeah yeah she was cool with it recreate
that sort of true facilitate that I
still like the buddy cop comedy where
they go out and try to find women who
are lactating who are also into it
together I love that too
I would watch that film a hundred
percent yeah but very nicely that's not
like they're like assassins allowed on
trainers how many months have you ever
thought about squatting that Teddy you
know a mouse
why yes I have